this is recording yeah good feelin
laughs for me Jerry we're in trouble you
understand please laughs yeah thank you
thank you all right let's get this
review on the road whoa
Robocop is one of the best movies of the
year and it's only February how did they
do that how did they already make a
better movie of the year for films I
have not even seen yet that is an
impressive movie I don't give a [ __ ]
about the 49 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
okay
I [ __ ] dug the hell out of this film
it's actually a really serious film and
it's actually pretty fun you know it's
not like with the trailers would have
you believe it's not like that wall wall
action flick this is that rare sci-fi
movie that is packed with characters
packed with story actors great variety
pack of great directing packed with my
[ __ ] can't come up with a secretary
right off the bat the story of this film
yes it's of course gonna be somewhat
similar to the source material but what
I thought was really different was the
focus on Alex Murphy like this doesn't
feel like a Robocop story like it feels
more like an Alex Murphy story
comparable to like how Tony Stark is as
feeling like Iron Man like how Peter
Parker is to spider-man like how the
Wayans brothers are to the white chicks
this movie immerses you into a world it
becomes about can a man become a Robocop
without sacrificing the most important
thing in the world
there's soul and you know what most
recent ex-girlfriend you're a [ __ ] cuz
you don't have one tell your name Ellen
Page thoroughly she's gay [ __ ] broke
my damn heart how dare she
she broke this man's heart right here
took it apart into two who cares we
can't get a sex change on whatever it
takes to make it work so the more this
movie progresses the more
psychologically gets and I guess the
best way to tell you about this awesome
[ __ ] possum script is to tell you
about its characters no kidding
it's Alex Murphy as Robocop I don't care
if I said it wrong shut up this actor is
awesome what I really liked about this
film is they get you to really like Alex
before he becomes Robocop you know a cop
cheers about his partner his black
partner you always need a black partner
in one of these movies and I got one
play the black partner Tyrese Gibson you
see that he's a family
and yes I see that this is a man who's
good at what he does and he likes doing
what he does and before he's about to
bone his hot-ass wife damn car blows up
[ __ ] his penis could have blown up
instead that doesn't make any sense I'm
talking about he's Bonin his wife he
could've blown up you calculated
basically is what I'm trying to say
nobody becomes Robocop it's not like
five to ten minutes of him struggling
over the fact that he's Robocop no
that's becomes a big focus of the film
throughout this journey ask to learn to
embrace the reality of everything he's
become like there's the shame of what
he's become the shame when it must be
like to be in front of your family how
to be a Robocop he has to sacrifice his
emotions and his freedom that's what I
did for you Ellen and you just betrayed
me I'm doing in my judo email account
you [ __ ]
you inception my mind it's getting me to
believe that we could love each other no
more hard candy for you he does the idea
is Alex Murphy no is he still a human or
is he just a machine but Joel he does a
great job in the role I call him Joe
doesn't matter I hang out sometimes it's
not just him being a robot it's a real
3-dimensional performance and yes fans
of the show you know what's coming next
I would totally suck Robocop's metal
dick Dead or Alive you're coming on my
face
Gary old man has the Doctor of Robocop
Gary Oldman has this incredible ability
to just disappear to any role he does
from him sitting and just doing nothing
you're like I get the guy he's that
doctor who creates for a buck off but
still wants to keep Alex human he wants
to keep his emotions present his
emotions are the gift of life and so is
birth and so is when you are saved by
our Lord and Savior if you don't get
saved your [ __ ] sorry wait is this a
good Christian behavior Jerry I'm not
gonna offend anyone yet he still has to
like sacrifice parts of his own morality
because he has to take you know some
brain parts of Robocop out there to make
him less human cuz he has to get a
Robocop to become like some super cyborg
they say the further he goes the more he
has seen you know sacrifices Oh morality
what does he do and that struggle you
really feel because Gary Oldman is
[ __ ] awesome oh it's totally suck
Gary Oldman's dr. dick that's two in one
episode
Michael Keaton is the man in charge of
putting robots in America he's the man
responsible for funding the Robocop
operation it's
as a greedy side to him Michael Keaton
he brings the world to life this could
have easily been a 2-dimensional
performance but he turned into a
three-dimensional performance uh-huh
the guy's great this is a master
manipulator but at times you like like
him at times you trust him like
especially like the first 20 minutes
hanging out with a guy you're like yeah
he's pretty cool dude I'm not ruining
anything for you it's not twisting the
film he's he's not necessarily the
nicest you know he's not necessarily a
good guy he needs to get more leading
roles and Buster Keaton and Gary Oldman
play off each other really well
Sam Jackson in a way he's like the
narrator of the story he does it through
his news programs he's a ton of fun
watch nobody else could have done this
role as well as him he's the best
character do trust these political
issues with and like I said ain't
jam-packed with action but the action oh
it's [ __ ] sweet but I really liked
about the action is that it's not every
action scene is the same they actually
mix it up a lot every action is
different and it makes sense why that
action scene is there at that point it
doesn't feel like oh they just threw in
an action scene it feels like that makes
sense for the plot what which of course
means a special effects of dynamite the
designs are awesome I even like the
Robocop black suit and it made sense
when he got the black suit I wish I was
black I'm just so much more intimidating
the actor has the perfect body to make
the suit [ __ ] man I want to cuddle with
this guy the film even has a bomb
soundtrack hopefully I do really
elaborate about that I don't really
remember the music I started watching it
going good music checkmark and then I
high-fived the Asian guy next to me and
he was like it is good music Ryan Wright
you know my name is a fan of the show I
invited Hayden I totally sucked my Asian
friends dick so yes acting great
directing and writing bomb
cinematography [ __ ] yeah
visual effects and designs are awesome
the film is the [ __ ] let me get straight
to the point here oh no I gotta save
Robocop got it super duper right
alright guys checking out my review for
a Robocop once you go ahead scroll
through that comment box below and tell
me that Robocop be played by a Japanese
guy and if you want to see more episodes
that's straight to the point
Shh I really don't remember what the
size of the box is 7/8 like this and
last but not least you wanna get updated
every time one of my reviews is out
going to clear this but about my dig to
subscribe that's right
the dig let me tell you something about
this little Robocop he's a remake from
the 1980s that's right that it's
surgically done twice the size hard as a
metal and I'll always thank you for your
cooperation citizen